first of all I would like to say that we
asked for support to protect those
volunteers and their families inside
Syria we didn't aim at getting anyone
outside but because the international
community failed to ensure protection of
civilians inside Syria and particularly
for the humanitarian workers and the
white helmets the last resort for for
those volunteers were to to escape
through the occupied Golan Heights too
short and then have resettlement in
other countries we sank the German
government and all our friends who
supported this process and we believe
that our colleagues who will arrive here
they will be active in their new
communities carrying their skills and
qualifications they will work to serve
civilians there as they did in Syria
okay but who will do the important work
of rescuing civilians in Syria if these
people have left the country we remain
committed to work for the Syrian people
wherever they are and we are aware and
whenever we have access to support them
the the group of volunteers who were
evacuated with their families represent
just a small percentage around 100
volunteer and their families but we
still have more than 3,000 volunteers in
northern Syria who continue their work
as usual the Assad regime says that the
white helmets have connections to
foreign powers and indeed to jihadis
what's your answer to that I would say
that the all these narratives are
contradicting each others sometimes they
say that the white helmets do not exist
at all these are just fabricated films
and sometimes they say those are
affiliated with Western intelligence and
sometimes that they say they are
affiliated with jihadist and all these
stories contradict with each other's the
true story that the white helmets are
from the people are working for the
people and their success and providing
assistance to the people and supporting
the civil society
it challenges the narrative that is
proposed by the regime and its allies
that narrative that say that there are
no good people left in Syria and there
is no civil society in Syria and the
Syrians are not able to walk by
themselves to help themselves it's only
the dictatorial regime or the extremists
this is all negative and for this reason
they try to throw these fake accusations
on a personal level you must have seen
some terrible things during this war in
Syria could you describe what motivated
you to join the white helmets in the
first place I of course I faced personal
challenges and big risks but it's just
like all other Syrians and all other
victims in Syria I would say that I
started this work and because it's my
duty you don't need a motivation to work
for your country or to try to rescue
your neighbor or your relative or your
friend it's it comes from values and
humanitarian principles when you hear a
cry from a baby or from whoever asking
for help it's our duty to do that and we
can't abandon our people as long as we
can do something to help it's our
responsibility and we will keep doing
this for to the end